eu interior ministers are due to hold a
meeting on migration later today they
will discuss the growing crisis on the
border between belarus and eu members
latvia and lithuania thousands of
migrants are currently stuck there after
being lured by belarusian leader
alexander lukashenko he has sought to
use the migration flow as a way to
pressure the eu into lifting sanctions
journalists are banned from the border
region but dw's nick connolly received
mobile phone footage from one of the
people stranded there take a look
thirty men women and children from
iraq's kurdish region stuck in no man's
land for days and nights at a time under
the gaze of armed border guards
latvian guards ahead of them and the
russian guards behind them
unable to move forward or go back
their only contact to the outside world
through mobile phones kept going by a
few precious power banks one of them a
young man called rawa sent us these
messages
you just need a help because
they're so cold and the children
all of them seek and not have a milk and
not have any food at here
like thousands of other iraqis these
kurdish families believed that belarus
would provide an accessible and more
importantly safe route to western europe
avoiding the risks of crossing the
mediterranean
they entered belarus legally on tourist
visas and made their way to the latvian
frontier their aim was to then cross
into eu member latvia before moving on
to germany and other western european
countries
they were soon stopped by latvian
authorities as this footage from
wednesday's shows but instead of being
taken to refugee camps for processing
they were taken back to the belarussian
border but not before these migrants say
the latvian authorities threatened and
beat them even using a taser stun gun
they
hitting us by electronic i don't know
what is this name but this is a
electronic thing that's so bad for the
humans
they do that with us
latvian authorities are adamant that
belarus is a safe country for migrants
from iraq and that if they should
require asylum they should apply for
protection there
rather than accept migrants and process
them in their own refugee centers latvia
is attempting to prevent them from
crossing the border in the first place
deterring rather than detaining them
several days into their odyssey these
migrants have it seems given up their
dream of reaching germany and just want
to go home
just we want us to deport us to iraq
because they saw
we so
bad and we're so tired
and no one help us
but even if they are to be deported one
side will have to blink and let this
group leave the border to fly home to
iraq
one thing though is certain when rawa
and his group set out from iraq they
could hardly have imagined they would
soon find themselves as bargaining chips
in a much bigger conflict between
alexander lukashenko belarus and the
west
which he and his group understood little
until it was too late
[Music]
dw has asked the latvian and belarus
border authorities to respond to those
migrant claims of brute force mentioned
in that report but neither authority has
made a statement yet